The immune system basically protects us from pathogens.
So, a pathogen is a virus like the common
cold
or it's a bacterial infection or it's a parasite.
And these pathogens can make us really sick
and our immune system protects us from these.
The way that the immune system does this is that it's very good
at telling the difference between what's self
and what's non-self
and so non-self, obviously, is anything like a virus or bacteria
so our immune system is very good at
picking up anything
that doesn't belong to our bodies and rejecting it.
All cells in our body
have a very distinct set of markers
or proteins on their cell surface
and these act as a barcode and the
immune system can read
these cells, this barcode, and it immediately
sends a signal
that that cell is foreign and not part of the
body and needs to be destroyed immediately,
or that it's a self cell and it's fine, harmless, leave it alone.
So these Devil Facial Tumour Disease cells should
automatically be recognised by the devil
immune system
as something that's foreign, that's come
from another animal
but for some reason that doesn't happen.
The way that this cancer, in the Tasmanian devil, does this is that it changes what it looks like
it puts on a disguise
they're changing the proteins and markers they have on their cell surface
which means that the devil immune system can't see them.